bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici à bruxelles au parlement européen
c'est parti pour 30 minutes d'actualité
cette semaine on s'intéresse au libre
échange c'est à taffetas statut
d'économie de marché de la chine on va
essayer de décrypter et de comprendre
avec mes invités de quoi il s'agit mais
d'abord direction bruxelles le ceta
justin trudeau est attendue la semaine
prochaine pour ratifier le traité de
libre échange entre le canada et l'union
européenne mais depuis quelques jours il
y à quelques couacs dans la ratification
c'est lucile devillers qui nous explique
c'est en grande pompe que justin trudeau
premier ministre du canada est attendu à
bruxelles la semaine prochaine but de sa
visite signer le fameux c'est a traité
de libre-échange entre le canada et
l'union européenne
fruit de plusieurs années de
négociations une signature qui réjouit
la france reçu par justin trudeau manuel
valls entend faire du canada le premier
partenaire de l'union européenne si
l'union européenne ne s'engage pas dans
un accord positif gagnant gagnant avec
le canada avec qui l'union européenne
demain pourra-t-elle bâtir de tels
accords de libre échange une position
pro libre échange qui dénote avec le
taffetas le traité transatlantique en
cours de négociation dont la france
demandent l'arrêt par la voix de
matthias fekl son secrétaire d'état au
commerce extérieur de son côté le
parlement européen votera le ceta en
décembre prochain
mais pour appliquer définitivement le
traité de libre-échange avec le canada
l'union européenne a besoin d'un vote de
tous les parlements nationaux
seul ombre au tableau deux parlements
régionaux francophones de belgique ont
voté contre
la wallonie par exemple est frileuse
quant aux conséquences sur son
agriculture et ses normes sociales
aujourd'hui moi j'ai dit très clairement
devant mon parlement ce matin il y a des
réticences que je comprends parfaitement
dans cet accord il ya des choses
intéressantes mais il ya aussi des
points qui nous pose de sérieux
problèmes on en a averti la commission
européenne on en a averti les autorités
canadiennes
il ya plus d'un an malheureusement ça
n'a pas suscité beaucoup de réactions et
donc aujourd'hui nous disons en l'état
actuel je ne pourrais pas signé je ne
pourrais pas donné les pleins pouvoirs
au gouvernement fédéral et donc nous ne
pourrons pas signer ce traité ce qui je
le conçois bloque tout le processus
un blocage qui risque de mettre en péril
l'accord depuis ce vote les pressions se
multiplient sur les parlementaires
belges
hors de question pour les européens
d'abandonner son état à l'heure où le
taffetas et quasi mort né alors quel
avenir pour ce settat pour se traiter
entre l'union européenne et le canada
pour en parler je reçois une grèce le
bonjour je vous êtes députée européenne
allemande vous êtes donc vous siéger au
sein du groupe ppe parti populaire
européen en face de vous emmanuel maurel
bonjour bonjour vous membres du groupe
socialiste et démocrate bienvenue avant
enfin franck proust vous êtes vous aussi
membre du groupe ppe les républicains
français et vous êtes depuis quelques
jours le président de la délégation
française c'est la publicité sion alors
là on voit bien qu'il ya un blocage sur
le s'étant déjà moi ce que j'aimerais
comprendre sait pour quelle raison il
faut que les parlements nationaux vote
et pourquoi la wallonie bloc franck
proust est les parlements nationaux
cents et la décision de monsieur juncker
alors que l'ensemble des juridictions
parti du principe que ce ne devait pas
être un accord mixte je crois que
monsieur juncker a cédé sous la pression
des populismes et d'un certain nombre de
gouvernements socialistes dont la france
pour que les parlements nationaux
s'exprime c'est pas une mauvaise chose
en soi sauf que la problématique c'est
que ça engendre l'unanimité et que qu'il
faut sur les 28 parlements nationaux ce
même si c'est même plus que ça il y en a
36 puisque la wallonie la panique la
belgique y en a trois et donc le
problème aujourd'hui et ça pose le
problème de l'avenir de la politique
commerciale européenne sait comment
peut-on obtenir aujourd'hui sur un
accord quel qu'il soit lunel lunel et
des 36 parlement vous aurez toujours une
région qui ne sera pas d'accord et là le
problème mais vous l'avez dit dans votre
reportage c'est comment trois millions
trois millions et demi de wallons arrive
à bloquer le destin de 500 millions
d'européens
la problématique elle est là parce que
cette règle d'unanimité nos aujourd'hui
est véritablement un handicap alors
emmanuel maurel
enfin paul magnette inquiétez donc le
quai le ministre président de la région
a été reçu à l'elysée par par françois
hollande il ya une pression monumentale
qui s'exerce sur les wallons pour que
ils reviennent sur leur vote notamment
dans le cadre en fait de la réunion du
conseil des ministres du commerce
extérieur est ce que la wallonie doit
revenir sur cette décision
je remarque qu'il ya plus d'émotion
quand la whl wallonie bloc le ceta que
quand le luxembourg bloque toute
harmonisation fiscale en europe
ou quand un petit pays beaucoup plus
petit que la wallonie d'ailleurs bloque
toute législation sur le dumping social
mais je reviens sur ce que dit franck
rossa l'instant parce que tous les
accords de libre échange que l'europe
négocie et ratifie ne font pas l'objet
d'une double ratification européennes et
nationales pourquoi spécifiquement sur
le ceta c'est pas sur la pression des
populistes c'est plutôt parce qu'il ya
des inquiétudes dans tous les grands
pays d'europe et on a vu la station ces
derniers en allemagne en france en
italie il ya des gens qui s'inquiètent
qui ont des doutes qui sont circonspects
et auquel il faut donner une réponse
or comme la commission pendant des
années s'est obstiné à négocier des
accords dans une opacité totale en
donnant l'impression fausse ou pas on en
discutera qu'elle agit essentiellement
pour les détenteurs du capital pour les
grandes multinationales et pas pour les
jambes est évidemment on se retrouve
cette situation où est bas il ya une
demande d'explication daniel morel c'est
si mal cecilia malmstrom était il ya
quelques mois devant ce même parlement
wallon elle aura fait en fait une
adresse pendant deux heures et leur
explique qu'il ya eu aucune question est
ce que là on n'ait pas un peu pardon
dans une posture politique à je ne crois
pas mais je pense que les wallons ont
discuté et ont échangé des arguments qui
reflète d'ailleurs les arguments que
nous nous échangeons en france ou en
allemagne
la différence c'est que l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat pour l'instant
n'ont pas été saisis mais vous verrez
que quand ça sera le cas il y aura le
même débat et une incertitude sur les
résultats parce que qu'on soit de gauche
ou de droite
qu'on soit favorable au libre-échange ou
favorable au juste échange ou même au
protectionniste sert quand même un débat
très important pour l'avenir de l'europe
et donc moi je trouve que cette crise
est les bienvenus elle est opportune
parce qu'elle a le mérite
elle est là la mairie
de poser des vraies questions et de
réponses de gens qui s'inquiètent et
quand les gens s'inquiètent et qu on
leur répond pas évidemment c'est tous
les fantasmes qui peuvent se développer
mouassa cette vertu higuain est ce que
vous êtes d'accord est ce que finalement
on est peut-être aussi dans un blocage
est ce qu'il faut arrêter de négocier on
en a un par exemple de traité de
libre-échange qui entendent se négocie
avec le japon est-ce qu'on a été trop
loin est ce que finalement les opinions
publiques n'en veulent pas non pas du
tout je crois que dans le cas belge
il y va de jeu interne belge c'est le
sel sel la constitution belge qui oblige
le premier ministre avant de signer
l'accord
le 28 10 maisons et la démocratie c'est
normal de demander de demander l'accord
de tous les partis de tous les six
parties de son pays
là dans notre pays ça n'existe pas donc
même les grands pays où il ya des débats
dans le fond on ne m'aime pas ce débat
dans le fond qu'en belgique jeu là je
crois que on est en train de la belgique
est en train de nous ridiculiser en
entier dans le monde entier et nous
ridiculise elle nous ridiculisent parce
qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas près d'une
épave capable que le chef de 2 chez le
chef d'état en belgique signe ces
accords là si on ne signe pas ces
accords là on va perdre la crédibilité
dans le monde entier
alors comment comment va-t-on gagner
encore de l'argent dans le commerçant
quand il n'y a pas de règle quand il ya
que les règles de dubreuil d'orgue nsm
bienvenue aux règles du commerce
on gagne beaucoup avec ces accords
nabeul pourquoi ces accords là sont en
débat vous savez je suis maintenant 14
ans membre du parlement européen
personne n'a jamais demandé quoi que ce
soit sur ces questions là juste avant
avril 2014
ça a commencé avec leurs fédérations
européennes comme c'est assez le modèle
pour le taffetas alors tout
l'américanisme antiaméricanisme dans le
continent ça rend maintenant c'est un
très très important et très intéressant
je crois qu'il faut commencer à séparer
les départs mais noël c'est vraiment
c'est une argumentation un peu du vieux
monde la vérité c'est pourquoi les gens
se posent des questions sur le commerce
international parce que il voit bien que
dans ces accords que tout le monde
présente comme gagnant gagnant car en
réalité
il ya quand même beaucoup de perdants
j'écoute perdant notamment chez les pme
les salariés européens mais c'est lequel
vous devez pas refuser ce débat qui est
très important j'en prends pas ce que
vous dites sur la belgique parce que je
trouve que c'est un peu condescendant
quand c'est l'allemagne qui bloquent des
dossiers ou quand c'est madame merkel
teddy moi je peux pas négocier sans
demander l'avis du bundestag
vous êtes moins un but moi je reviens
quand même sur le fond du dossier parce
que le texte
au moins franck proust et moi même on
l'a lu le cetas fait quasiment 1800
pages il pose quand même un certain
nombre de questions la première question
c'est les gains économiques ont dit on
fait ça on signe ce traité parce qu'on
espère ça va donner de la croissance et
de l'emploi
le problème c'est quand on regarde les
études sur lesquelles s'appuient même la
commission l'étude la plus optimiste
elle dit ça va créer à horizon 10 ans 0
point 0 3% croissance mais par contre
quand on regarde la vérité contrôle de
commerce internationale ria ronald
gardant quand on quand on regarde un
accord de commerce international on
regarde les îles et risque au regard des
opportunités au niveau des opportunités
je vous les 10 les plus optimistes 10 0
20 et 0 3% de croissance mais par contre
en terme de risque sur l'agriculture par
exemple pour l'emploi là ils sont réels
c'est ça dont on va discuter sur le
contingent agricole que ce soit pour le
boeuf le porc c'est quand même 60 milles
puis 75 mille tonnes est-ce que alors
même qu'on est confronté à une grave
crise agricole est ce qu'on prend ce
risque sur la question environnementale
est ce que d'ailleurs on n'arrête pas de
faire des indes en dom des propositions
nouvelles parce qu'on se rend bien
compte que y'a rien sur les questions
environnementales dans ces états c'est
normal que les questions soient posées
et qu'on ait ce débat français c'est
vraiment un risque 1 écoutez comme l'a
dit monsieur morel et j'ai bien lu ce
texte 1600 pages en plus pour la
première fois la commission européenne a
fait note interprétative pour traduire
ce dossier qui est quand même un dossier
très technique avec une note politique
et juridique
nous avions défini il ya 70 des lignes
rouges comme pour les négociations du
taf taille la grande différence
on va y revenir a dit mandat c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas au bout des
négociations alors que là on peut juger
sur pièce sur ses 1600 pages ces lignes
rouges
nous avons obtenu une satisfaction dans
tous les domaines nous avions demandé la
réciprocité nous l'avons je rappelle
simplement que alstom à l'époque n'avait
pas gagné le marché en ile de france
quinze ans de carnet de commandes se
viderait au gouvernement socialiste de
faire une commande artificiel pour
sauver alstom bombardier avait gagné à
paris et surtout bombardier avait gagné
à montréal le métro alors qu'alstom ne
pouvait pas répondre nos agressé grâce à
sa gueule assez grasse demain ça ne se
reproduise parce que mon corps je suis
pour la mondialisation je partage l'avis
de ma collègue mais à une condition
c'est que tout le monde joue avec les
mêmes règles
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui avec le
canada réciprocité des marchés publics
défense de notre agriculture avec la
défense de nos idées ppc la première
fois l'indicateur géographique protégée
qui associe la production d'un produit
un terroir très important cent quarante
ans noah au sénat on a parlé de nos
pronos de nos fromages qui ont fait
polémique mais 143 iger p protéger c'est
la première fois ci le caron guay jusque
là donc à rien de figé mais il ya une
protection protection et donc ont su
vraiment gagner en fait des biens diane
engagé ce qui me paraît important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ma quand j'écoute les
entreprises quand j'écoute nos
agriculteurs quelle est la situation
est ce qu'aujourd'hui les chèques par
exemple du ceta serait une avancée est
ce que nos entreprises sont protégés est
ce qu'on peut avoir de la croissance
vis-à-vis d'un pays comme le canada
comme le g7 c'est toute la crédibilité
de l'institution européenne parce que le
problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'au bout de
70 travail où il ya des fonctionnaires
qui ont travaillé où on nous a donné
tout ce que nous souhaitions
et bien pas une posture politique d'un
gouvernement qui représente 3 millions
et demi d'habitants on emprunte bloquer
le destin encore une fois de plus de 500
millions d'habitants il ya un autre
dossier qui nous occupe aussi beaucoup
c'est le type ou le taffetas parce qu'on
a on a finalement un peu de noms et en
france notamment à l'arc est dans une
posture un peu pas très clair mais ça on
va y revenir parce que la france est
très contente de signer l'état mais en
revanche sur la position vis-à-vis du
type là pour le coup on n'en veut pas
nous on a été voir des entreprises
françaises qui l attendent après ce type
reportage à calais et à paris de cécile
siksou
une caresse sur le fil ce geste france
beaudoin l'a appris il ya plus de 30 ans
comme beaucoup de calaisiens
il a commencé sa vie professionnelle
dans la dentelle il y avait énormément
de gens qui travaillaient en dentelle
bon je peux je ne peux pas dire de
chiffres exacts mais on va tourner
autour des vingt mille salariés a calé
ce travail et même le week end
aujourd'hui le constat est que il ya
plus à fut rien on antenne sur calais
c'est tout à s'agresser c'est un petit
peu moi je prends soin comme une mine de
charbon on est en train de s'éteindre
il faut malheureusement
pour michèle bernier et gérard dezoteux
les co gestionnaire de deux seuils
l'étincelle pourrait venir du taffetas
le projet d'accord de libre-échange
entre l'europe et les états unis leur
pme revient de loin
placé en liquidation judiciaire il ya un
an elle a été sauvée par un repreneur
chinois et un plan d'investissement sur
les années à venir en aide à peu près 4
millions et demi ce qui dans notre
industrie est encore considérable
64 personnes ont été reprises est d 1
des embauches sont planifiés en fonction
de la reprise de l'activité et plus
spécifiquement sur certains services
notamment le dessin à la création qui
restent les fers de lance de 200 ayant
créé des emplois tisser de nouveaux
marchés michèle bernier espère désormais
retrouver le chemin de la croissance
grâce aux taffetas us ou parisse lui
aussi voit le taffetas comme une aubaine
car son entreprise se partage entre
l'europe et les états unis s'est produit
on les voit partout sur les billets de
banque
les pièces d'identité ou encore les
articles de luxe des hologrammes des
dessins en surbrillance difficile à
reproduire ici on a un produit qui en
fait va partir au brésil pour la
protection des passeports loisirs brésil
philippines chine des rouleaux entier
destinés à l'export en 30 ans à pme est
devenue un des leaders mondiaux en
matière de sécurité sur iis aujourd'hui
c'est environ 400 collaborateurs
nous exportons dans 113 pays à peu près
95 % de notre chiffre d'affaires est
exportée donc la france en tant que
destination finale d'utilisation de nos
produits c'est à peu près 5 % de notre
activité sont implantés physiquement en
france aux états unis en landes et en
allemagne deux pme françaises
intéressées par le taffetas ce traité
propose de libéraliser le commerce entre
l'europe et les états unis en réduisant
les taxes douanières mais aussi en
simplifiant les règles de commerce entre
bruxelles et washington
chez de seuils on peine encore à
s'exporter chez l'oncle sam
l'un des plus gros marchés mondiaux du
textile et de l'habillement des droits
de douane de 15% et les normes
réglementaires très exigeantes comme
l'obligation des tests d'inflammabilité
des tissus de teneur en plomb faut
grimper les prix de la dentelle parfois
jusqu'à 25%
du coup face à la concurrence des pays
d'asie
la pme ne fait pas le poids ce traité et
donc la promesse de nouvelles parts de
marché à l'étranger mais pas seulement
nous fabriquons un produit intermédiaire
qui a utilisé en grande partie par des
marques de lingerie européennes qui
auraient ex porte sur la marché
américain donc si je pouvais voir
difficultés à exporter ce soit d'ordre
tarifées en réglementaire facilité par
ricochet nous les revendre ayons donc là
c'est marc des quantités de dentelle
sans doute plus importante encore
indirectement on profiterait également
de ses facilités à exporter de nos
propres clients pour l'entreprise series
autre problématique déployées sur le sol
américain avec sa filiale spécialisée
dans la protection des plaques
d'immatriculation ces produits font
régulièrement des allers retours au
dessus de l'atlantique
le tata pourrait alors simplifier les
échanges ils ont des codes douaniers qui
sont pas tout à fait les mêmes que les
nôtres
ils veulent des descriptions de produits
qui sont pas forcément ans précise mais
si elles sont pas assez précises sable
aux endroits
en fait on se retrouve parfois des
marchandises bloquées en douane pour
finalement pas grand chose et on va
perdre une semaine
ou une denis semaine ou deux semaines
juste à attendre que loigné bien
vérifier nous est demandé des paquets
d'informations sur la composition des
produits sur son utilisation esterra
donc il faut prévoir du temps
gain de temps croissance création
d'emplois comme sur les haies de seuils
beaucoup d'entreprises françaises croit
en l'avenir du taffetas elles ont
pourtant du mal à donner de la voix
face à une opposition grandissante
on
emmanuel maurel alors c'est quand même
une aubaine pour ces entreprises
pourquoi vous par exemple vous êtes
contre le taffetas mais évidemment savez
quand on négocie un accord pour échange
par définition la première chose qu'on
regarde ses droits de douane skis et ski
et ski et dans le taffetas c est ce qu
on peut baisser les droits de douane au
maximum ça c'est bon pour les
entreprises des deux côtés
après ya la question de l'harmonisation
des normes techniques et ça c'est un
c'est très intéressant et très important
ce qu'on fait dans tous les accords de
libre échange
1 quand la prise électrique n'est pas là
même de le côté de l'atlantique ça
pénalise un certain nombre d'entreprises
c'est bien qu'on discute à l'essence est
une aubaine mais mais mais il n'y a pas
que ça dans la négociation sur le
taffetas c'est l'harmonisation de toutes
les normes notamment environnementales
phytosanitaires sanitaires là ça pose
plus de problèmes et puis surtout on
parlait tout à l'heure du ceta mais dans
le taffetas pourquoi ça bloque la
négociation c'est parce que les
américains ne veulent rien lâcher sur
l'ouverture leurs marchés publics
d'une certaine façon et c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont un peu pas lundi ils sont
encore plus intelligents que nous c'est
à dire que ils ont des protections et
notamment dans les appels d'offres
publics
il ya une partie qui est réservé aux
entreprises nationales voire local la
deuxième chose sur laquelle ça bloque
fort et et franck proust
il faisait allusion c'est la question
des indications géographiques aux etats
unis ils sont dans une logique de marque
il fabrique du bris dans le wisconsin du
parmesan un peu partout et ils voient
pas l'intérêt
alors que nous européens c'est vraiment
au coeur de notre identité de lier un
produit à un terroir un savoir faire à
une technique
donc ça bloque là dessus puis ça bloque
aussi sur la question des normes dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
l'agriculture américaine ne fonctionne
pas du tout comme la nôtre que même si
on met des garde-fous le risque comme
elle aurait oui bien sûr alors bien sûr
à partir du moment où c'est interdit par
la législation européenne on va pas dire
que ça va être importés en europe sas et
ça c'est sûr mais mes chers franck
proust ya quand même un problème c'est
que ya ce qu'on appelle le chill effect
c'est à dire que on anticipe on anticipe
un problème de convergence de normes et
on va vers le bas regarder sur les
paires de perturbateurs endocriniens
pourquoi la commission est moins à lente
qu'avant et pourquoi elle revoit ses
exigences à la baisse c'est parce
qu'elle sait que au niveau américain
évidemment ils en sont pleins on
pourrait dire la même chose d'ailleurs
c'est dans le cadre du ceta sur la
question des sables bitumineux là aussi
là
la commission avait baissé un petit peu
ces exigences parce qu'il y avait
l'accord avec le canada il faut être
faut être vigilant là dessus
puis enfin sur le taffetas pourquoi ça
bloque c'est surtout parce que les
américains ne veulent pas que la
nouvelle ne veulent pas négocier sur des
points qui nous tiennent taclera nouveau
inge graisseux est ce que le mandat de
négociation finalement du taffetas et
pas du taffetas pardon et pas trop large
finalement il dirige le même même pas
aboutir juste que vient nous expliquer
les manuels morel je crois que le
taffetas c'est une grande chance pour
l'économie européenne
si on veut vraiment sortir du chômage
mais j'ai compris que la france les
socialistes français veulent pas sortir
du chômage c'est que vous avez montré
avec les peu mais ce sont des exemples
l'impression de il y en a tant
localement que les cultures il y en a
dans tous les pays
et c'est pour ça que si maintenant nous
on fait rien on n'aura rien on n'aura
pas plus qu'avant c'est ce que la
plupart des gens ne comprennent pas
il faut vraiment il faut vraiment hâte
rapport aux échéances vous savez les
américains nous sommes beaucoup plus
globalisé est beaucoup plus ouvert nos
marchés européens que les marchés aux
états unis même s'il connaît encore en
train de négocier pour la voir avec les
marchés publics
c'est déjà beaucoup plus que ce qu'on a
maintenant c'est pour ça que je mènerai
effectivement emmanuel maurel nous
explique qu'il ya une forme de
protectionnisme aux états unis que vous
n'avez pas accès à leurs marchés publics
qu'est-ce qui nous est sûre aujourd'hui
dans la négociation ils vont mourir mais
c'est justement ce à quoi les
négociations sa taille mais les
américains et sont 600 organisations de
standardisation lors on peut me dois
demander à qui s'adresser quoi faire
chez nous il ya 28 il ya un seul
négociateur cette profession beaucoup
plus simple les frais sont beaucoup
moins il ya des normes techniques aux
états unis qui sont là pour protéger les
situationnistes mais pourquoi les gens
pourquoi nous avons peur nous sommes
meilleurs que les américains nous ne
pouvons que gagner nous sommes meilleurs
ce meilleur que les américains feront
que c'est vrai oui avec un peu d'humour
je dirais qu emmanuel maurel il est à la
fois contre ce qui existe et contre ce
qui n'existe pas parce qu'à la limite je
peux comprendre sa position sur le c'est
à yale ses 1600 pages qu'ils existent
s'est réalisée on a obtenu satisfaction
surtout mis tellement d'ail et sur la
place et du vent aujourd'hui puisque 90
on en est au 15e ronde de négociations
c'est pour ça que la position de la
france
c'est complètement incohérent prête à
signer cet appel ne veux pas mais pas
n'importe quelle condition bien entendu
si on n'obtient pas satisfaction sur la
réciprocité des marchés publics comme
dit un monsieur morel sur l'alignement
des normes vers le haut on va pas nous
politique crée un accord qui ne
protégerait pas à la fois nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises notre
responsabilité en tant que politique
c'est créer un environnement politique
qui est capable pour nos entreprises
d'aller chercher la croissance là où
elle existe parce que quand vous avez en
europe un taux de croissance qui varie
entre 0 et 2%
il est important d'aller chercher la
croissance sur les pays riches du g7 et
surtout sur les pays émergents
mais bon là on voit bien aussi qu'il ya
des études qui démontrent que le risque
c'est cinq cent mille ans peut pas
détruit aussi on attend dé moi les
études
vous savez les études de même de la
commission européenne et là je partage
l'avis de déménagement elle mais elle
s'avère jamais exact en tout cas peu de
fois je prends un exemple le dernier
contrat de partenariat avec la corée du
sud
signature 2011 application provisoire
depuis cinq ans puisque les parlements
nationaux se sont tous exprimés à ce
jour sur la validation de cet accord a
l'époque monsieur montebourg avait crié
et avait poussé des cris d'enfants 10
ans va détruire le secteur automobile
cinq ans après qu'est ce qu'on remarque
que 77 % de nos exportations ont été en
progression et qu'on a multiplié par
quatre nos parts de marché sur le
secteur automobile et qu'une marque
européenne a racheté une marque sud
coréenne
ça veut dire wen hsin à redon c'est une
réussite c'était bien entendu ça
démontre que de temps en temps a parfois
la commission aura les uns les autres
parce qu'elle va pas dans le sens que
nous souhaitons
mais par contre quand elle fait des
choses et de bonnes négociations il faut
aussi avoir le courage de le dire
et qu'aujourd'hui les accords de
partenariat justement si pour
réglementer ce libre échange sauvage lee
engendre des fermetures d'entreprise et
détruit des emplois
si on veut réglementer les liaisons
commerciales surtout par exemple entre
les états unis et l'europe qui sont les
deux premières puissances c'est la
meilleure protection que nous pouvons
avoir contre le le continent asiatique
comme un emmanuel maurel a juste il part
de la prise
je prends souvent l'exemple de la zoé
était un formidable produit
beewi inexportable parce que on n'a pas
réussi à obtenir la norme mondiale
et s'il ya une norme américano
européenne qui s'imposent
elle s'essaie aux normes la tête à
s'imposer demain au continent chinois
par exemple et c'est 25% de
compétitivité en plus alors eux ils
gagnent assez rapidement oh bah on ne
fait qu' on ne fait que pour faire
profiter la chine de la faiblesse
européenne si on n'arrive pas à conclure
ni de cette année le taf sa
non-sélection vivent en profiter et koné
mais économiquement et la russie
politiquement et dans ce cas la chamade
mais il faudrait que vous à la fois
comme représentant de la droite et
représentants de la droite allemande
vous battiez avec nous pour que ya une
modernisation des instruments de défense
commerciale face à la chine
c'est moi ce que je comprends pas c'est
ce discours qui consiste à dire fois
adopté le ceta et le taffetas vous avez
raison tout à fait qu'il ait pas encore
si un jour on a accès à certains
documents on voit paris mais les
négociations sans graisse que la
négociation donc il faut d'un côté on
dit faut absolument signer ça mais de
l'autre on ne fait rien face aux vrais
dangers qui est l'accession de la chine
à l'est au statut d'économie de marché
avec tous les risques que cela comporte
pour l'industrie européenne moi c'est ça
que je comprends par la transition est
toute trouvée parce que justement au 15
décembre prochain il ya une date un peu
de butoirs 11 décembre prochain date
butoir on doit au niveau européen
décider si oui ou non on donne le statut
d'économie de marché à la chine c'est
quoi les risques emmanuel maurel de
données ce statut d'économie de marché à
la chine
les risques d'abord un las la chine
n'est pas une économie de marché
les chinois eux mêmes le reconnaissent
mais aujourd'hui ils interviennent sur
les marchés
ils interviennent sur les prix les aides
d'état sont massives
c'est une concurrence libre et c'est
exactement ce n'est pas une économie de
marché 2 6 pour autant il accède à ce
statut pour une raison ou pour une autre
on va pas pouvoir leur imposer leur
opposer plutôt des armes anti dumping et
de ce point de vue là c'est une grave
menace pour un certain nombre de
secteurs l'acier et le verre quelques
années avec la subtile qui a été
des exactement quand l'équateur était
donc là vraiment des sur un sujet très
politique qui normalement devrait
mobiliser et la droite et la gauche
à partir du moment où ils ont à coeur
l'intérêt européen c'est de dire
défendons-nous comme le font les autres
parce que la réalité c'est que les
américains par exemple il n'hésite pas
il tergiverse pas pour être des mois
pour une forme de protectionnisme en
grèce le est-ce qu'il faut donner ou pas
ce statut d'économie de marché à la
chine assc ya pas trop de risques pour
notre économie
bien sûr la chine n'est pas une économie
de l économie de marché là on est on est
entièrement d'accord vous a mis l'accent
sur le fait qu'il ne faut pas lui donner
ce statut absolument parce que si on
regarde l'économie chinoise et ce qui
est ce qui se fait là il faudra même
plus de plus de douane il faut imposer
dans la même taille que fait le canada
et les états unis
oui parce qu'effectivement les droits de
douane à au canada ou aux états-unis ont
été largement augmentée pour protéger en
fait leur marché et proust qu'est ce qui
va se passer alors est ce que la
commission est sur cette ligne
quelles sont elles sont là je le
souhaite elle doit que moi que je
constate c'est que pour une fois les
socialistes et les conservateurs fallait
tpe sont d'accord parce que j'ai on
essaye d'avoir de la cohérence moi j'ai
été élu pour une europe qui agit et qui
protège ou des dit tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui la mondialisation oui à
condition que tout le monde comme en
sport joue avec les mêmes règles
aujourd'hui l'europe a défini cinq
critères pour faire en sorte de
d'octroyer ou pas le statut d'économie
de marché de la chine la chine n'en a
qu'un et encore parce qu'on a une une
large vue d'esprit donc lui donner le
statut de l'économie de marché
ça serait encore discréditer les
institutions européennes donc
aujourd'hui il ya un manque de
transparence fiscale et sociale
la meilleure défense c'est de ne pas
octroyer le statut d'économie de marché
dernière question très rapidement est ce
que la commission européenne est sur
cette position est ce que le risque
c'est qu'on n'est pas des mesures de
rétorsion de la chine pour nous obliger
en fait à nettoyer ce statut la vérité
c'est que cette pression il existe des
gens elle existe déjà à regarder sur
comme la chine participe au plan juncker
oui ils essayent quand même leur
diplomatie économique essaye de dire ben
c'est donnant-donnant quoi et le risque
est grand
vous avez aussi ce que moi je regrette
c'est quand vous discutez avec les
représentants des états membres pas
seulement la france
il vous explique on va pas monter au
créneau préfère que ce soit vous le
parlement européen qui le fasse parce
qu'on a peur des mesures de rétorsion
c'est la grosse solidarité avec un
manque de solidarité évident alors même
que là c'est un sujet qui devrait
mobiliser tous les états membres
et quand je vois je vais vous dire que
c'est la grande bretagne qui prend la
tête des états qui veulent pas
moderniser nos instruments de défense
commerciale alors viennent de grossir et
xi le break cite moi je maintiens marche
sur la tête
et donc il faut pas que l'europe soit
l'idiot dû village planétaire et que sur
cette question
elles se défendent parce que sinon
évidemment les gens ils n'adhèrent pas
au projet européen et on les comprend
ouais et là l'enjeu ce sera aussi
peut-être de mobiliser nos citoyens à
l'image de ce qui s'est passé sur le
site assure le taffetas et peut-être
donc sur l'économie de marché le statut
d'économie de marché de la chine
merci à vous de nous avoir éclairé sur
ces dossiers qui sont quand même assez
technique
nous on se retrouve bien entendu la
semaine prochaine pour de nouvelles
d'actualité européenne très belle
semaine à tous ciao